Hello and welcome to today's episode of Clustered
on Rawkode live.
Wow. Today is the first version of Clustered
Teams and I'm very excited to have a
team from container solutions and a team from
Civo Cloud here
to fix some rather broken clusters broken by
each team.
Now before we begin on that, there's just
a little bit of housekeeping.
First,
if you're not subscribed to the YouTube channel,
please do so now. This is gonna get
you alerts and notifications for all new episodes
as we explore the cloud native landscape
together.
Also,
Teleport joined us last week as a sponsor
of Clustard and I was just the easiest
decision I've ever had to make when it
came to this show. Teleport has been the
software we've used ever since the second episode
and makes debugging and fixing and pairing on
broken clusters
well, as easy as it can be, but
you know, still painful. Right? It's Kubernetes.
So thank you Teleport. It's been a pleasure
working with you and I'm excited to bring
Teleport to more people.
Okay.
Housekeeping done. We're gonna start by fixing some
broken clusters and we've got a great lineup
today.
Popping over here,
I am joined by team container solutions.
Hello all. How are you today?
Hello. Hey.
Panicky at all. Not panicky at all. No.
No. I I have no idea how today's
gonna go. Like, I'm so excited I'm so
excited for teams edition, but also logistically, I'm
like, this is gonna be interesting. I'm really
hoping that as three colleagues, you're all just
gonna be pairing together
perfectly and harmoniously. Right?
Yes.
Yes. I think we should start by pointing
out, although we work together, we we're not
on the same team, we don't answer as
well.
I met I met Adrian today for the
first time.
Okay.
Well, why don't oh, apparently I'm a bit
crackling. Alright. I'll fix my big Kai. Thanks.
Can you all do me a favor starting
with Charlotte, Ricardo, then Adrian just say hello,
tell us who you are and we'll get
started on today's cluster.
Of course. Hi, everyone. I'm Charlotte. I'm an
engineering manager at Container Solutions.
Still do some technical things every now and
then, so we'll see how this goes today.
Ricardo?
Oh, sorry.
Hi.
I was looking at Adrian's.
Yeah. My name is Ricardo. I'm a I'm
a cloud native engineer at continuous solutions. I've
been playing around with Kubernetes for the over
a year. I'm having a lot of fun
there.
I'm based in Portugal.
Hi. I'm Adrian.
I should have my surname because I don't
know why you can't call me as Adrian.
But, anyway
yeah, I'm chief scientist at Container Solutions, but
I really look after our labs projects. So
it's like all our open source projects at
Container Solutions.
So whilst I do do a fair bit
of Kubernetes, it's on the development side, and
I'm not really used to maintaining clusters. I've
done notice I'm getting my excuses in fast.
Nothing wrong with getting an odd excuse in
early. All part of the game.
Alright. So here are the rules.
You have
forty minutes
to work on the SQL cloud cluster.
Your mission is to upgrade the cluster deployment
from the v one image to the v
two image,
be able to access the application,
see the quotes,
and the video.
Simple.
I have I also caveat this. I have
no idea what either team has done to
their clusters. I will be of no help
whatsoever to you. I am here purely for
moral support.
Now, I'm gonna pop up our screen share
like so. This
is teleport. I will open the first session
on the control plane node for you. If
you can all join
and just give me an echo hello to
let me know that you're yet let you
let
me know that you're there and if you
wanna nominate one of you to start with
a typing that might work best.
I'm not sure. We'll see.
And I'm just gonna spend today's session looking
at the chat. Alright.
We got an echo hi. So at least
one of you and
two. Alright.
Who quotes their echoes? Come on.
That makes sense.
Alright. It looks like we have three guests
all in this session.
Disappointed
with the lack of all caps from you
guys but this is okay.
Alright. This best not to start fighting just
yet. He's gotta work together as a team
to fix this. Alright. You'll need to set
up your cube config and any aliases that
you need and then if you want to
do the honors and check for a API
server, it's usually a pretty good place to
start.
Yeah. You be an existing. If you want
me to set up the cube config, I'd
be happy to do that. If you want
to it yourself, please feel free.
Ticket Charlotte says you type in. Right?
Yes. Is that alright? Am I so slow?
Works for me. There's a feature request for
teleport, actually. We need colored cursors so we
know who's typing. Certificates.
Why?
Current time is after
last year.
So certificates expired.
Classic.
Oh, it's a date. No. Hang on. Oh,
jeez. Check the current date. It's a date
in the past.
Oh, current time today.
That's fine. Current time's after. Oh, yeah. Okay.
So that's when the certificate expired, is it
2020?
Who wants to go to renew certificates?
For all the searches, under manifest?
API server.
There.
Why
So what's because that number does oh.
Alright.
I was just gonna say what cert does
the kubelet use? The API server or something.
Is that API server cert? I mean, I
know it's in the kubelet config.
Don't know.
The 2019 is what I mean about here.
Yeah. I'm loving the timestamps on those files.
Oh, I can scroll in here. Yes.
You can each scroll independently.
If there's something you want me to show
to the audience, let me know and I'll
do my best to scroll on my side
so they can keep up.
Oh, cool. Okay. Okay.
I mean, these ones. Right?
Is one of you looking at part of
your new certificate?
I thought we just set the date two
years in the past and see what happens.
We had a comment from that in the
chat. Diego is suggesting just change the date
on the machine.
There
are rules to clustered and messing with the
dates will break all certificates and couldn't teleport.
So we'd probably lose access to the machine,
but I do not recommend it. That's good
to know. But
then we're done. We just go home.
Yeah. I have no idea to rotate the
certificate to be perfectly honest.
So So you can use QPDM to renew
search. You don't need to learn open SSL
commands or anything like that.
Yeah.
There is actually PDM. So I see I
see you're onto it now. I can't see
the bottom of the screen.
You
can't see it. Can't scroll for some reason.
If you can't scroll, if you just like
resize your window a tiny little millimeter, it
seems to fix it.
It's a
it's just a wee frustrating. But like if
you just like
drag the corner of your browser window and
make it a little bigger and then a
little smaller, it try it fixes the scroll.
It's like a sync event that happens when
people join. I'm not really sure what what
the problem is.
Alright.
What's that?
The CVO team are vocal in the chat
and they say they're here if you want
hints.
No. We'll try and fix this first. That's
gonna be the stone snippet when I publish
this after you you feel measurably Adrian.
We'll be fine. Sorry.
That's harsh. That's harsh for me. Okay.
They're all involved.
Up next, it's Jason.
Yeah.
I
guess we're pointing out. Doesn't matter what the
project does. It's not just shell. Does that
sorry. Let me go.
Okay.
We
can't we can't even do that because we
can't talk to the
Good. I need to need to start with
the API server.
Yeah.
No. Yeah. I think there's no dash.
Isn't there renew everything that's expired?
Is it dash dash l? Oh, yeah.
I'm doing my best on ace. It's just
the all there.
And there's no Did you try to renew
all before? Didn't like it.
I tried this with minus minus, but. No.
Look at that.
Okay. And let's restart.
Restart everything now though. System c t l.
Yeah.
Oh, those are the pods. Right? Oh, if
I restart the cube load on this one,
it should restart everything.
So these are
It's looking healthy.
Good.
Hey. Think Okay.
Okay.
Yeah.
Looks good. I hate whoever does start breaking,
by the way. No offense to see what
he can has been broken, so I'm gonna
be completely useless again.
Alright.
Although maybe it could just be affected by
the
So some configuration error in Cilium.
That's your first ten minutes down. You've got
thirty five left.
I'm sure that's all they did. I'm sure,
Sivo, were really nice to you.
I hope.
This node shell. What's that node shell completed?
That looked weird.
That worries me. This node shell completed the
job thing.
Must keep the system.
Hube API server isn't running. Oh, no. This
isn't ready.
There's a lot of restarts we've got there.
Yeah.
Are you seeing a different screen for me?
Me? Because mine says cube based, so we're
fine.
It looks fine over here too. Mine mine
is fine as well.
Adrian's working with one of his own clusters,
I think, here.
That's called up. Okay.
Just gonna look and see them for now.
It says restart once because it worked when
restarted. That's all it is. I was looking
at the old one.
Oh,
you're scrolling in your own version? Okay.
Yeah. It still works.
So what are you thinking right now? Any
ideas?
I'm thinking we cannot connect to the Cyllium
agent on the worker, which makes sense because
the worker isn't running.
I'm getting a lot of helpful info from
the pod itself.
I thought you're gonna say for me.
Which would be accurate if I tell you
anything about Cilium.
I mean, can we I think you already
Yeah. So it looks like the Cilium crash
that back off is on worker x c
x. Would you like me to open a
session on that machine?
Yes. But give me a second first.
Of course. So I'll check if it's in
the logs.
Where? I lost my screen.
Okay. I'm back.
Difficulty isn't oh.
I do love the delete all approach. That's
one of my favorite techniques on this show.
You've been criticized about several times I believe.
I know. Because that's how I also usually
upgrade applications and people keep giving me grief.
To be fair in this case, the only
ones I wouldn't have had to restart are
the Hubble ones and they probably don't break
anything.
Uh-oh. Uh-oh.
What yeah.
Must be sticking that.
That's the API server
IP. Correct?
That's
not looking healthy.
Yep. I lead the star approach.
The delete hammer of doom.
So what does it mean if you've got
deployments, replica sets and no pods?
So usually, I'd say that's something with a
scheduler,
but since
oh, right. I checked for the pod and
not the record. Oh, because it's
let's check here.
What was that? Is that the screen port?
No. It's for the record. Yeah.
Replicas two current, two desired, zero running, zero
waiting.
Desired as a two.
So
you mentioned scheduler.
What was your thought process there?
Usually, when a pod doesn't show up, it
doesn't show up at all, like, isn't that
means it isn't scheduled. Right?
Can you Shall we check the configurations there
and see? You
could do cry CTL and see the pods
are running there, but it needs to be
in the work or no.
Give second.
These
ones were worrying for you. Right?
And maybe we wouldn't delete any more pods
for a bit.
It's really not those.
Feel like he's walked into a bear trap
there.
So I'll give you some
info. Like if it was the scheduler, the
pod would be created.
It would just wouldn't be assigned to a
node yet. It wouldn't be able to be
created.
I
but I don't see anything there. I don't
see anything to resemble a pod.
Nobody could just schedule and you'll know it
doesn't even stuff there.
Sure.
Some great taps from Waleed in the chat
if you want me to pop one on
the screen.
You. Network policy.
Alright. The replica set is not creating, then
check the controllers and the API server.
No controllers.
Look at the API resources as well.
They're not there. That might be Yeah. There's
no controller manager.
Okay.
Really suggest that Siebel have invented a new
technology, invisible pods.
This isn't particularly useful, unfortunately.
Siebel do build some pretty cool stuff, but
I'm not sure if that's on their road
map.
Where did the
static pod logs go? That was bar log
containers.
What is this node shell stuff? Have a
look at that. Is that something normal?
No.
What's in the log?
There's no logs in there.
That's rubbish.
Okay.
Can we run system CTL as well? Maybe
there's something Still looking at the schedule logs
for a second.
It looks fine, though.
Isn't it? Just your system system CTL status
as well.
That's on
yeah. That's on here.
Yeah. One for sure.
Do the do those have services, the scheduler?
I don't know.
Yeah.
So have confirmed that node shell is nothing
to be worried about. It's just part of
k nine s, which I think they were
using for playing around.
Okay. Line 38
in Oh, look. Could not process mine. There
you go. I think you found it.
Yeah. Okay. So there's something wrong and there
was Kubernetes
manifest.
Yeah.
A shame there's no GitHub code pilot for
Vim. Yeah.
Did you hit Vim there? Because the first
the place where it started might have been
That's that's that's always a good giveaway I
found.
Oh, yeah. Because that's a pub.
What's the Vim command to show spaces and
tabs?
Something? I don't remember. Was just curious if
anyone knew.
I don't remember.
Can can you see the whole of that
on your screen? If
I scroll to the right, you can't?
Oh, maybe I can. Don't know. So
with journal control, there's arguments to the it
wraps it properly. If you need to do
it again, I'll I'll throw one out at
you.
At mission control
Sorry. Yeah. Was is there a mission controller
running? Let's just kill any of the mission
controllers.
Burn them in hell. I'm gonna get a
t shirt that says it's always with mission
controllers
except when there's finalizers.
Mission controllers are added here somewhere. Right? API
server?
Depends what type of admission controller.
Yeah. It run you know, when that is
API resources or just gets
admission controls.
I gotta agree with Nolan. This putting tabs
in YAML is evil.
Yeah. Actually,
it's gonna. Sorry.
No.
No. No. That's It's a great tip to
cat dash t apparently.
I'm assuming shows tabs.
Didn't know that. Oh, really? Yeah. Cool. Oh,
nice.
Okay. So
Webhooks.
I can't remember. Who's googling?
We can just do kubectl
get under Webhooks now. Yes. You can do
a Kube control get, and there are two
types of admission controller. There's validating
web configuration
and mutating. Yeah. Yeah. So Kube CKL get
and validate the mission. Yeah.
I suspect there's gonna be mutating, but anyway.
It Permission was a validating wrapper configurations.
And unpacked.
And mutating.
Yeah. You can also run kubectl API dash
resources to get a list of. Yeah.
Oh, look at that.
Describe it, I suppose, or that or kill
it.
I would have failed it if the describe
works. You know, I don't know. Deleting pods
got you in trouble earlier. So, you know.
Yeah.
Daily policy fail. So it's not gonna yeah.
So that's not gonna let you start new
pods. So that was
that's probably what's So the So the starting.
Yeah. So that would make sense. Right? The
the pods didn't come up, and it's because
that was stopping it.
All of these faults or things the civil
team have done or had customers done to
themselves. That's good to know. Real world situation.
Themselves.
Like, it was all your fault, customers.
Did we get rid of the machine tool
or what's that one?
Yes. That was deleted. I deleted it. Yeah.
It's
always funny when those things come back, though.
Nope. I guess. Yeah. Yeah. I got any
pods starting up?
No.
Oh, if you're looking to see your news,
there's pods coming up.
Cilium
Oops.
Pending.
So
Nice.
Okay.
Who's got the show in the background?
Mommy.
Yeah. I think it might be on my
side.
Sorry about that. It's all good.
You're in Portugal, so can't even make a
football joke.
That'll be too easy.
Fifteen minutes ago, I was still there. Okay.
Oh, it's kind of funny when I scroll.
I'm
not quite sure.
Well, at least you've got pods that are
just pending there.
Yeah. This failed to fetch token doesn't sound
great, is it?
That's thirty minutes ago. That was thirty minutes
ago. Think that was still a certificate.
Yeah. Can we
can you describe the replica set or the
pod? Can we
did it give us a
indication why it was pending?
Yeah. If you just scrape the pods, you'll
get the event on. Because it's still
Yeah. It's still mentioning the certificates.
Yeah. Because they're not assigned to any node
yet.
But if we describe the replica set, will
not tell us what's If you describe the
pod, it will tell you what it's waiting
for.
I mean, events are usually at the bottom.
Right? So that should
There's a
Charlotte's first guess was right.
No. No. There's none. Scheduler? Indeed.
So
We fixed the static manifest. What do you
call them?
We fixed the controller manager.
We did not fix the scheduler
if that is broken. There's two. Maybe I
looked at the wrong one. Why don't we
just do now the star shell and see
what the edit is?
I'll do a find dash dash anything.
Find slash. What are you looking for?
I'm just one of the edited other commands,
other stuff in the it's the Kubernetes.
So Adrian thinks to modify the static manifest
for the scheduler.
Yeah. You're doing LS dash AL.
They might have changed the
Oh,
nice.
K. What's the problem there?
Is.
Yamal. Yamal.
Sneaky.
We're doing ALS. ALS just to see those.
Oh, so very long.
Mhmm.
You have fifteen minutes left.
No pressure.
That's fine.
Oh, fine.
But that's Is it fair to tell you?
These are these are finding finding problems and
fixing them. I'm impressed.
So what's currently broken?
It's still the pending pod
because the scheduler is still not there.
We still have no scheduler. Where?
I think it might be coming up.
So I was hoping.
But some of them are running.
Yeah. Yeah. The schedule is running, but the
pending is still there.
Hubbell's down, but do we care?
I don't.
Hubbell.
Come on.
What happens?
Paint. There we go. One node just oh,
I hate things.
What was that?
Paint and then minus. Right?
There's Maintenance through. There you go.
No scoreboard buttons. Maintenance through
taint.
Yeah. How did I do that?
I have no idea.
No idea.
And note
You can do a 10 And then the
minus at the end. And then the yeah.
With the minus.
Oh, yeah. That's a bit weird syntax, isn't
it?
They love the minus syntax in Kubernetes.
It just means that it's dash.
This one? Yeah. That should work.
Dash dash all. Sorry.
Alright. Back to Kubernetes. I'm not using word
certificate. The cube admin thing anymore. Okay.
Well, that's that's impressive.
Okay.
Oh, look at that. Alright. Something's actually running.
So do we how do we see?
Yeah. You wanna check it now?
Yes. Yeah. What's the but that that should
be public. Right? Because we have the There's
a node port on it, 30,000.
Yes. But I can't see the external IPs
from on here. That's alright. I can fill
it up here or you can just curl
it from the machine, whatever you prefer.
You know, you don't sound particularly confident that
this is working.
It's working. There you go. You got version
one running.
It's hard to tell which oh, yeah. Version
one.
Oh, okay.
No. Don't update it. Can should we check
it's okay.
What do you mean?
I want to see the web page. That's
all I mean. Oh, I put it up.
Sorry.
Mean We did cam thing. That was good.
Yep.
Back up again. Letters me looking at my
watch saying you're running out of time.
Oh, yeah. I see it. No pressure.
I didn't I didn't do what you said.
I don't have the other thing to the
side.
Yeah. It's probably just pulling the image unless
they've left any more sneaky breaks on there
for you.
It's pulled. You could do dash w, you
know.
It is running.
Could. But it this is better for my
anxiety to just constantly do the same thing
over and over again.
You
got the dance. You refreshed. Oh, really? Is
that v two? Yep.
Charlotte, you did this all by yourself, by
the way. I think Yeah. You did. I
was I was doing business.
Well done. Team continuous moral support.
Also,
thank you for people with the hints. I'm
I'm very glad and thankful and grateful for
any kind of hints always.
Alright. Well,
team Sivo, if you wanna start making your
way to the link, team consider solutions.
Thank you very much. Well done. You smashed
that and you still had
nine minutes left for further debugging. Sorry
Charlotte. You smashed it. Adrian and Ricardo. Thanks
for joining us.
Alright. If you just want to drop off,
thank you again. I really appreciate that and
I'll speak to you also. Thank you. Alright.
Thanks. Bye bye.
Alright. You're stuck with me while we wait
for the civil cloud team to join us.
And I'll just take this opportunity to say
thank you to Teleport again for sponsoring.
It's a pleasure to have them on board.
We use this tool every single week on
clustered and it is just a fantastic tool.
If you have a Kubernetes cluster, you should
deploy it. Check it out. It's great on
bare metal too.
Okay. Let's hope the latency is not too
bad and civo are gonna start piling in
any moment now. Oh, we do. Perfect.
We got
the Nash. Hey, mate. How's it going? Oh,
it's I am too. Thank you.
Awesome timing.
Let's get your names on the screen. So
we're just waiting for David to join us
as well and then we'll get started with
the next cluster.
How is how is that watching that?
Yeah. It was
They did really
really well.
Did they They
did. I gotta say and there were some
really
really fun see as soon as I seen
the search I was like, ah, that's because
those are so painful to fix. So that
was cruel that you went for that but
some
nice ones, the YAML I got I love
the double a on the YAML as well.
I
didn't even notice it as well. Like I
just thought it looked fine to me so
very sneaky.
Okay.
Hopefully, you all got registered with a teleport
for the container solutions. So I will pop
open a session in just a moment, but
first, if we could just get some introductions
from y'all, please feel free to share a
little bit about you and what you do
and then we'll get started on our next
cluster.
Dinesh, we'll start with you and then we'll
we'll move around.
Do you want to introduce yourself?
Oh, sure.
This is going well.
Yeah. So Dinesh, director
of innovation at Civo. I've been working with
Kubernetes for years and years and years.
And, yeah, it was nerve racking watching that.
Well done.
Our brains if David's in our brains, our
excuses are coming out now, but we've been
on a p one since midday today.
So we we actually got it fixed. I
was on one of the default calls ten
minutes before this started. We're
we're leaving it all to say I'm here.
No. You're not allowed to practice before a
cluster. Come on. That's too much.
Especially in production scenarios.
No. I'm glad you got that fixed, and
I'm glad you could make it today. Thank
you, Denise.
Sam?
Yeah. There needs no introduction, but I'm gonna
let you do one anyway.
Yeah. Working as direct reflecting evangelism
at Civo. And,
yeah, I'm a CNCF ambassador.
Do tons of stuff for the community and
run my own YouTube channel as well. I'm
happy to be here. Let's see
what has container solutions
have for us.
Thank you. And, David?
Yeah. I'm one of the site reliability engineers
for Civo.
The only American part of the engineering team
over here. I don't have the pleasure of
being in the same country as these guys,
but we get a lot done.
Just like to say, good job, Container Solutions.
We tried to come up with some ridiculous
stuff. We came up pretty well on that.
Awesome. Thank you all for joining me. Let's
get this party started. I don't know if
I can call it a party, but I'm
gonna call it a party.
Alright. I have here our teleport instance from
container solutions. I am clicking connect
on the control plane node. Please use the
activity menu on the left. Find the active
session and join and if you can type
echo hello, make sure you're all in there
and then we'll get this underway.
Call it cursors teleport. That's what we need.
Please make it happen.
Alright. I think we got everybody there. Awesome.
Okay. I think as customary on custard, you'll
wanna set up your cube config and check
if you have a control plane. Let you
just take it away from here. Good luck.
Have to decide who's gonna type first.
Who have we got typing on there?
I guess me. Gonna
do a x export of cube config.
Yeah. You wanna do that?
I'm driving.
I typed slow.
Hey, Mark. Welcome to the party. Oh,
it's content.
Someone from the container solutions team has said
there are some hints and slash root have
required.
You will need those hints. Know it.
Things seem like they're running, which is interesting.
Job done. Well done. You fixed it.
I
doubt that highly.
Well, there's a deployment that's not running.
Looks alright to me.
Hey, Jeremy. Welcome to Clustered.
Comment from Kubernetes community days UK that someone
forget to break the cluster.
Clusters can be deceiving. Even when they're working,
they're probably fucked anyway.
Air mounting pod filters of sandbox.
Uh-oh.
On the
control plane
and the scheduler,
What time was that?
A while ago.
It did say that the scheduler was running,
didn't it?
Mhmm.
Four hours ago.
That's worrying.
Copy.
Paste.
Failed to list nodes.
Connection refused.
Check IP tables real quick.
Kai is asking is it just a flash
wind? Oh, it's looking a bit different now.
We'll see. Alright.
Unless what's the default policy, it's fine.
Do you think anyone's ever enjoyed working with
IP tables?
No. Hang on. 6444.
That's not 6443,
is it? And
that one's been changed.
Interesting.
Is it in the config scheduler config?
Or is this just been properly messed with?
My head is spinning with ideas here. Yep.
There you go. There it is. Yep.
There it is.
See, they're getting back at us for YAML.
Should get restarted.
Yeah. They could be able to detect the
change. It may just take thirty seconds to
a minute for that to
to respond it.
Oh, wait. No. It won't. Because we've changed
the scheduler config, not the manifest itself.
Uh-huh.
So let's just touch that, and that should
sort that out.
Should sort that out.
I hope that wasn't someone's pager.
No.
Spam runs.
Do we delete it?
Well, you could run a p s a
u x and see how long the process
has been running.
Or a f x. Nice touch.
You can always touch the p s flags.
Keep sketchy that.
One forty six.
Oh, that just done it.
No.
Take away and kick the pod.
Delete.
Nothing ever bad happened from deleting a pod.
I'm just saying. Yeah.
That's still not done it. Let's delete it.
Khalid is asking who's wedding. The audience is
winning as we're all absorbing knowledge today.
Here we go.
Yeah. That looks better.
I mean, does look better till you did
that.
Yeah.
Can we reschedule that?
That does look like it should have been
changed.
Oh,
I know. Copy paste.
I'm assuming that
So why would that not be picking up
the
right config file?
Do wanna just restart the cube with maybe?
Oh, shit. These all been spelled right.
Is that you checking for Unicode?
That looks right.
Looks okay.
Yeah.
What's happening right now is we have a
scheduler running. You're looking at the manifest. It's
using scheduler.conf,
which you've just modified,
and it still appears to be broken.
Yeah.
It's using
proper image. So it's not that that's been
messed with or has it?
Is a
Is your scheduler.com
definitely still 6443?
Yep.
Yeah. The logs from the pod
are 6444.
Interesting.
Is there a service config
file in, etcetera, Kubernetes
for the scheduler itself?
Sorry. I gotta what did we say?
You wanna drive? At yeah. Looking at etcetera
Kubernetes,
so we can
look here.
There might be another.
So we have that one
and
Cubelet one.
That was my idea. So
just check them once again.
What's in there?
Probably looks like install time.
You definitely restarted the scheduler. Right? That that
that restarted.
It's definitely a new one as of three
minutes ago.
Should we restart the cubelet?
Maybe we should burn down the note.
Oh, it's getting hard.
I'll get them.
Copy paste.
That's another thing for teleport. Copy paste on
on highlight.
I was gonna ask if you just want
a hint, but I don't even know if
that's wrong. But I've I've
got an idea.
What's the idea?
Right now you're working on the assumption that
the static manifest live in that directory.
That is true.
So
this is a cube admin cluster, isn't it?
It is a Kubernetes cluster.
ETC Kubernetes
manifests.
Damn.
Which is where we were.
So the other thing I'm thinking is that
it uses
host path volume mount. So
unless there is the
scheduler dot yaml
somewhere else on the find file system.
It's
a tricky one.
Yeah. Is.
This is
Ricardo has dropped a hint in the chat
for us, but he says a small edit
in scheduler dot YAML may have been better
than a touch.
Okay.
I'm not sure if c is Charlotte or
not or maybe Adrian with a third account,
who knows? But saying don't overthink it.
I think that was aimed at me, so
I'm just gonna shut up. Oh, yeah. Thanks,
pop. The key is do the opposite of
what I say. Alright.
That's
That
was it.
Thank you very much.
We just we we've done it. It just
didn't decide to do its thing. Alright.
So we've still not got that up and
running.
Nodes are still ready.
Welcome, Sam. Thank you for joining the academy.
So now you're looking at the replica set
and trying to work out why we we
have no pods. Right? Why it's, yeah, why
it's not being scheduled at all.
Exceeding quota.
Can you spell that?
So those are set on
the namespace, aren't they?
The limits
are
Are they
What was more challenging? This or your p
one?
Well, we still are not entirely sure why
the p one happened.
I mean, we're back up and running, which
was the key thing, but the root cause
is still unknown.
Use limits.
So where do the limits get set?
Is it get resources,
was it? Or
how do you get all of the types
in Kubernetes?
It's kubectl get dash resources.
Sorry. API resources. Forgive me.
No get. Just API dash resources.
Thank you.
Network policies.
What ranges?
Oh, gone.
Yeah. You you can do get limit ranges
or or quotas. Yeah. You just basically got
it.
I see we can just either edit that
resource quota.
Right? Edit, delete, and you get, and I'll
pick your poison.
I think edit it. Give it
Load.
50 m.
Does anyone really understand the m's on CPU
cores?
No.
No. It's really CPU. Is that self explanatory?
So 500 ms would be 500 milli cores.
Right? So half of one CPU. Half of
one. Yeah.
What's wrong with 0.5?
Come on.
YAML.
YAML. Damn.
Yes, Adrian. It is cube control and I
will hear the end of it now. Thank
you.
That's the status. You don't need to edit
that. So I think once the spec is
done, you can just save it.
And that was edited while you were editing
it. So
unless you're maybe okay.
Get pods. Is that been scheduled now?
No.
Just wanna describe that new replica set one
five
f
d b.
It's still there. Should we edit the pod
and delete the limits
the request?
Thanks, group daily.
I mean, I would just delete that resource
quota. I don't I don't think it's doing
you any favors. That's that's my advice. Yeah.
It's all changing your mindset from being destructive
with things to being like, we just need
to massage it into working because you don't
wanna cascade into more and more errors. But
As someone who has personally cascaded himself into
many subsequent errors on clustered, I will still
defend deleting things.
Yeah. The chats are green. Delete the quota.
There we go.
How's the quota actually gone?
This is still nine minutes ago.
Maybe.
Yeah. Has the
has the quota definitely gone?
I love it when you delete a resource
that comes back.
I
think you're good. Delete
the replica set and that should force it
to be rescheduled.
Just delete r s dash all
double dash all.
User twenty minutes in, twenty to go.
Twenty five. I can't count. There we go.
Hey.
The pineapple juice, Willit.
Wish I had some.
Pop, I will not stop talking, although I
do agree that Dinesh has a very soothing
voice.
Put that on the community chat as well.
I
feel bad about talking all the time.
And we check that, David.
What would you like to check? Sorry, Sayam.
This looks like
we have changed to v two. Right?
Yeah.
You can curl localhost on 30,000 if you
want or I can pop it open in
a new tab.
Yeah. I want to see the fancy
You wanna you wanna see the dance. That's
it. Right? Yep. Yep.
Local host. That's
not gonna work. I can't do local host.
But
Oh,
look at that. They have swapped out the
something.
That
is not my custard.
So I know in the
I know in Docker world, yeah, I can
do that with
CryoControl.
Images.
Sneaky,
Mary. Mhmm.
So I'll give you a hint just because
it's not always easy. We're gonna need to
set the runtime endpoint on cry control.
So dash dash runtime dash endpoint equals or
do want me to type it? Yes, please.
So it's bar run
container d container d dot stock.
What did I get wrong?
Here's me sounding all confident as well. Runtime
endpoint. Maybe
Do
you need a do you need a Unix
in front of that
to say it's a socket?
Or
I'm just gonna try.
There we go. I just had to come
before the command.
Adrian seems surprised that the the image showed.
Well played.
We might need to check on the MacBook
now.
Your Noise Gate is
pulled you out.
No. Noise Gate, MacBook today.
The
we wanna check that on the work that
happened.
I got none of that. Did anyone else?
I think David suggested checking
cryo control on the worker node where it's
scheduled.
Yeah.
So if you tell me where it's scheduled,
I'll open a new tab.
You'll need to set up cluster too. Yeah.
There's cluster of all the names.
That is on S 9 R 6 L.
Alright.
There you go. You have a session opened
on that machine.
Can I open that as a tab or
does it need to be a
like, kinda close this and No? No. You
can just open a new tab. If you
just go back to your first tab, you
should be able to join the active session.
It'll pop open in a new tab for
you.
I hope.
I think I'm not opening up a new
one. Let me close these and see if
I can put it.
I'll leave that session.
Alright. I have you all on this on
this node.
Is
that me? That is you. Yep.
Yep. Sam's there.
Must be getting late for you, Sam.
Yep. It's eleven.
Thank
you for staying with us. I appreciate it.
Alright. What are we doing on this working
note then? I have that in my pace
buffer.
Do we just wanna delete it?
Yeah.
And make sure it gets pulled again?
If you're driving, David, do wanna
yeah. Look. There's a 457
meg one there. That looks
Yeah.
I love the image ID across v one,
v two, and latest there.
Just
Is there a delete on this one or
is it just list?
I am not entirely sure if you can
delete an image with
with cry control.
Hey. Come on, chat. How'd you delete an
image on container d? Delete anything?
Request.
RMI. That would be a good chat.
Has someone got the YouTube page open on
the side?
One or more image ID.
Noel has said you can use CTR to
remove images. So check out the CTR command.
Or
Charlotte is suggesting cry control RMI will work
too. So
Yep. I think it worked. Right? Someone got
the YouTube page open on the side. I
think someone does have the YouTube side.
Someone's YouTube is
actually.
I hope it's not me.
Any other we want to do?
The all of the clustered ones. Delete them
all.
There's a matching tip from Seth in the
chat. You could always change the image pill
policy to always.
It's a good shifter.
Yep.
Delete it. Delete it. Delete it.
Still an LS again? Because I wonder if
it will keep it around if it's actually
running a pod,
which it doesn't look like it has.
Right. So I guess if we go back
to the the master, the controller
thing.
Indeed. That tab is front and center again
there.
And if I drive
which node did we it was s 9
that was known good, wasn't it?
It was S9. Correct.
Let's make sure it doesn't go over there.
Copy.
Paste.
Delete of the part to cut it to
be recreated.
I guess you want me to check the
image?
Oh,
that's still not work. I
saw you were making a bit of a
whale of assumption there.
Did you call on the right
worker node? Because I think it was on
s nine.
Yep. So I called them to the other
one. So you're making the assumption that the
break here was Adrian had pre pulled an
image pre pulled a broken image. Right? It
was. So the other thing it could be,
if we go back to the node, is
check the dodgy hosts entries.
Yeah. There is a new image actually on
the worker again,
which is
different one, I think.
Nothing
on the host entries.
So, yeah, it was either the the assumption
was either that it was pre called or
built on the node. I think I know
what it is, but I think it gives
you a better time.
I just do an images l s again.
Check check for images to see what's been
pulled.
I think someone's been abducted by aliens.
Images.
Images. Yeah.
That seven b
seven c b looks
remarkably similar from my memory for hashes that
I've seen briefly passing by on our screen.
That looks like it's So maybe we just
yeah. I would agree with that. Yep.
So
all we've done is change v one to
v two. It's pulled the right image in
theory.
There's nothing pointing it to a different
container unless there is a cry control
sort of proxy that you can do.
Sort of like the docker proxy. Is that
a thing with cry control?
So
I guess, I mean, I I
I'm assuming I know what it is and
I don't wanna give it away, but there
is a container d command that will dump
its config.
Okay.
Should we get that dumped on the
on the on the worker node?
Inspect.
Oh, no.
Inspect the
invite. No. Config.
Yeah. So
it's not on cry control. It's on the
actual container disk daemon binary.
So if you just type container d help
on its own.
Or you can look in the config.com, that
will reveal some of it. Yeah.
There is a honk.trowel.io
that looks
remarkably suspicious.
Good catch.
So container d has this feature,
which I don't think I have.
It allows you to
redirect container
rip up registries to other registries.
Guess, Simon, you're you're driving. Do you wanna
remove that?
You could also done container d config dash
dump, I think, as the command.
I have to say, I've still not played
around with Creo container d and if the
releases of Kubernetes,
where they're depreciating and getting closer and closer,
we really need to start to sign up.
You can you can cut call the
first
three level render two end Should we do
the container d dump one or we delete
from here? No. Just delete that line
and the line above it.
And that should be fine. You probably have
to delete the image again.
Nice break, Adrian.
I like that.
It was RMI, wasn't it?
Yeah. You know, you run just run it
from from your history because it's the same
ID.
Alright. And then if you get back to
the master and oh, sorry. The control plane
and delete the
delete the bot again.
There you go.
I never wait for that to delete.
Yeah. It's gone. It should have gone it.
What it's doing is it's waiting for the
next pod to start up and become running.
So the theory being that once it's deleted
and it starts up, you're like, everything's fine
and you can carry on, but everyone's too
impatient.
So I'm still getting
Does container d need to be restarted or
anything? Is that a thing? Yeah. You'll probably
will have to restart container d.
I got that.
Would be particularly
evil if they had found
another way to have that image delivered.
Do wanna delete the image again, David, while
you're on that?
Yeah. That will have been pulled again.
It will have been.
It looks like
yeah. Delete it. You should be good.
Adrian says it's on both workers, but they
have cardened the other worker, so we should
be alright.
Taking a little bit longer to come down.
Or is it not even coming down? No.
It will be coming down. It's just a
500 mega image I'm afraid. There we go.
Let's see.
Failed to connect the database. Oh, you got
more.
Damn your container solutions.
You got the angry man. So you have
one more problem that looks like the fix.
What pod is that? Postgres? Oh, sorry. What
node is the Postgres pod running on?
Sorry.
Whoever was driving can drive now.
No one's driving. Everyone's gonna be hands off.
So at least you've got a Postgres pod.
Right? That's that's a good start.
So that's on our other
worker as well. Suggest we delete it, and
it'll get rescheduled back on the right one.
And then if there's anything messed around with
IP tables, but Yeah. You didn't do MTD
around this, did you? That'd be terrible. Unless
Brooke's been messed around with as well, but
it looked
looks like Postgres is running.
Hey. I took Rawkode of the equation when
I built this application that uses a
and and a container and no PVC, so
you should be good.
Alright. I deleted that.
Just get wide again.
I'm just making sure that this is
Nice one, Seth. Container solutions,
more like container problems.
Yeah.
I was trying to come up with a
funny pun, but none of them were nice.
Do we have any endpoints on our postgres
service?
It's running now on the same node.
So let's check the service. It's the next
thing.
Yeah. I would describe the service. Let's check
for endpoints.
Even if I could spell, we'll be doing
good here.
Alright.
There is an endpoint on it. Does that
match the pod?
IP matches. Yeah. How about the ports?
Portal sign 5432.
Is it fine on the port, though?
Alright. He's got a few more minutes left
to think of this last problem.
If it's the last one.
Yeah. Ports are right.
Ports are right.
I have not so I've got connection timed
out. Is core DNS running?
Is
and hasn't been messed with well, can you
check the config map for core DNS?
It's not DNS.
Container solutions have confirmed that It's not DNS.
Oh, so they're not be able to connect.
Can we get a
shell on the clustered application?
Suggested if you look in the hints in
the root directory, hint three
for this problem.
I think it's slash route. And
then Charlotte's in there with a hint even
in the chat. What prevents traffic?
That's a pretty big hint, I think.
Well, it's gotta be potentially IP tables or
policy.
Yeah. Network policy. Yeah. I think you're right
to that. I think a network policy.
Don't look. Don't look. Check network policy.
We've had we've had a hint over the
chat, so
I'm sure it'll be the same one. I
hope it's the same one.
There go. Just delete it. You sure you
don't want to edit it?
No. That one seems mean, and I probably
learned my lesson.
Alright. So that is a network policy. I
should be able to just refresh this pretty
quickly.
We have the dance.
Awesome. Great job.
Lots of great problems across
both clusters there. I'm trying great fixing from
both teams as well.
And we're on time both clusters fixed. What
what more can we ask for? That was
awesome.
All right, great job Sivo. Thank you for
joining me. It was a pleasure. I hope
you had fun with that too.
Absolutely.
All right. Awesome.
Great. All right.
I'll say thank you to container solutions. Thank
you to Civo. Thank you to Teleport for
sponsoring today's episode and thank you to everyone
that tuned in and watched. We are looking
for more teams to join us on cluster.
So if your team works with Kubernetes and
you wanna come on and have some fun
with us, reach out on Twitter or the
GitHub repository or email me at david@rawkode.com.
To both the teams, thank you again.
I'll leave it there. Thank you. That was
absolutely awesome. I couldn't be happier with the
first episode of cluster teams. I hope you
enjoyed it too, and I'll see you all
soon. Thanks.
See you all. Bye.